الطفل محمد يأخذ نفسًا صغيرًا
مجهدًا بمفرده ، لا أمي لا أبي يمسك
بيده الصغيرة لم
ينج والديه من الزلزال الذي
تم إنقاذه من قبل الجيران البالغ من العمر ثلاثة أشهر
الذين أحضروه إلى وحدة العناية المركزة
في الغرفة المجاورة التي وجدناها  راليا ، البالغة من العمر
26 عامًا ، لن تمشي أبدًا مرة أخرى ، لقد
دمر الزلزال
منزل أسرتها وسحق ظهرها زوجة أبيها ،
أخبرتنا راليا وأطفالها الثلاثة
بقوا تحت الأنقاض لمدة 18 ساعة ، وقد
نجا الأطفال لكنهم لا يعرفون
مكانهم
في كل مرة.  غرفة في المستشفى السوري ،
حكاية مرّة حلوة للبقاء على قيد الحياة ، كان من المفترض أن
يكون الكثيرون على قيد الحياة اليوم لإخبار
قصصهم يقول الأطباء إنهم حاولوا
إنقاذهم لكن لم يكن لديهم ما يكفي من
الإمدادات لإنقاذ الجميع ،
فالمرافق الطبية القليلة في سوريا التي يسيطر عليها الثوار
بالكاد ما زالت  بعد
سنوات من القصف الروسي والنظام السوري
الذي تركهما غير مهيئين
للتعامل مع كارثة بهذا
الحجم ، فقدنا الكثير من الصبر
بسبب النقص
والإمدادات الطبية لو كان لديناهما لكنا
أنقذنا العديد من الأرواح ، كان
هذا هو المشهد.  هنا يوم الاثنين الماضي
وفي المرافق الأخرى التي تديرها
الجمعية الطبية السورية الأمريكية ،
هذه أكبر كارثة واجهناها على الإطلاق
مع إصابات الحرب ولكننا لم نضطر أبدًا
للتعامل مع هذا العدد الكبير من الضحايا في
الحال ،
صرخ الناس في هذه الأرض المدمرة طلباً
للمساعدة ولكن دون مساعدة  جاءت مساعدة الثوار
شمال غرب سوريا مرتبطة بالسياسة وتحت
رحمة نظام قاسي للغاية
حتى في وقت مثل هذا
يقومون بالحفر والحفر بأيديهم العارية
وأي شيء يمكنهم العثور عليه وهم
يحاولون يائسين الوصول إلى أحبائهم فقد
فات الأوان لذلك.  عمليات الإنقاذ الآن يريدون فقط
دفن موتاهم يبحث محمد
عن أقارب بلا تعبير وخدر
يخبرنا أن 21 منهم بما في ذلك
حياة الأطفال هنا تبدو وكأنها دورة واحدة لا نهاية لها
من الخسارة والحزن
لأولئك الذين شردوا مرارًا
وتكرارًا لأكثر من عقد من الزمان  من الحرب
أصبحوا الآن بلا مأوى مرة أخرى
كنا ننام تحت الأشجار ولكن
كان الجو باردًا جدًا لقد جئنا إلى هنا تخبرنا سلطان
أنها تطلب من المجتمع الدولي
أن يرسل لهم الملاجئ التي نريد فقط أن نضعها في
خيمة تقول أتمنى لو كنا قد متنا مع
الجميع  غير ذلك ، حتى لا نمر
بهذا ، تخبرنا أننا نجونا فقط
لعيش هذا البؤس والعذاب الذي
لم يبقوا فيه ليهربوا الملايين
محاصرون في إدلب ، إنها آخر
منطقة يسيطر عليها المتمردون في سوريا
تقول محمد إنها وعائلتها هربوا من حلب.
المقاطعة وأتت إلى هنا تقول إنهم
هربوا من طائرات أه المقاتلة والغارات
الجوية وتقول إننا أتينا إلى هنا
وتبعنا الزلزال ، وتقول إن
الموت يتبع السوريين في كل مكان
يعيش فيه 700 شخص في هذا
المجمع السكني المدمر الآن فقط حفنة من
الشباب الناجين من القرى المجاورة.  جاءوا
يركضون لمساعدة الناس على الخروج ،
أخبرتنا ، لكن ما الذي يمكنهم فعله حاولوا الحفر
سمعنا أشخاص يصرخون أخرجونا
وأخرجونا ، ثم هدأوا ،
ماتوا جميعًا بعد يومين ، سحبوا
طفلاً وفتاة صغيرين.
الدفء
في كثير من الأحيان الروح
[الموسيقى]
الآخرون يصنعونها بعد ساعات من
عملية الإنقاذ المضنية هذه ، تم
إخراج أحمد الصغير حياً من أصحاب
الخوذ البيضاء وقد بذل أبطال الحرب في سوريا كل ما في
وسعهم لإنقاذ أكبر عدد ممكن من الأشخاص
وناشدوا بشكل عاجل الحصول على
دعم دولي لم يفعلوه  أرسلوا
أي شيء
لم يردوا عليه ،
تركوا الناس هنا ، والآن
الناس هنا في سوريا يعرفون حقًا
أنهم الآن منسيون
الحمد لله.